practice squad players on the on the
sideline yesterday if that is the case
um why was that important for you to to
have them down there on the field right
they got a Raiders uniform them guys
bust their tails you know last week was
just two days this week it be three days
and they're getting us looks both on
offense defense special teams they're
working out in the morning they're in
the meetings they're in everything about
it but then on game day where are they I
you know I don't you that wasn't my
belief um I've been at other places
either as a coach when I was in high
school or college every in man if you're
on a team you're a part of Team you're
there on game day and and I just felt
the way that we practiced those two days
and what we asked them to do they
deserved to be on our sideline they
earned that right and I hope they don't
stay on practice squad I hope they push
themselves to become on an active roster
and that was the Carri I dled in front
of them and they brought energy on the
sideline now it was a little a little
busier than we used to than I'm used to
but you know what I'll take it when they
bring that kind of juice that they did